a lot of people are losing sleep over
this because kim's convenience is
currently in its fifth season
and the show announced yesterday that
this will also be
its last so there's only a few episodes
left and this entire thing
will wrap on april 13th
yeah the show says the reason is that
the for the abrupt ending is that the
co-creators movie gone to other projects
this announcement completely blindsided
the cast
oh my goodness yeah so posted on twitter
i am heartbroken i know what you're
thinking and to be clear i was fully
expecting to come back for our sixth
season
in fact i was probably more excited than
i've ever been in many ways i thought
john would be liberated this coming
season
and he would finally get to show some of
the growth that i had begged our writers
for year after year
it pains me that we will never see jung
figure out what he wants to do with his
life
i feel we deserve better i feel that you
our amazing fans
deserved better now vlaska says i'm
heartbroken i love kim's convenience
such a great show
samantha's love kim's that's odd because
i mean this show got hit such a bigger
following with
netflix when it uh got on there just
like shit's creek so
i'm very surprised that they would end
it so fast and like didn't the cast know
that the co-creators had other projects
they're moving on to raj like it just
seems
odd to me that they wouldn't be in the
loop they
yeah they did and i and i watched see
moo i i love i i love simu and paul and
everybody else on that show
um they're just such wonderful talented
uh people and they really built a family
they knew about this they did
create relieving and see me program live
last night because fans started you know
campaigning
cbc and netflix in what we've seen
before and it's been successful before
which is you know save
kim's convenience but this is one of
those cancellations where it was not a
network decision
this was the creators of the show
decided to walk away
before the sixth season that they had
already sold and so what do you do at
that point
which was incredibly tough but i find it
so wild that in the last
12 months you had paul who really just
like went out of this world with his
popularity because of his appearances on
the mandalorian and he is now like a
nerd god
and then you had simu off for a year in
australia
he's going to be a marvel superhero as
soon as that movie comes out
it was incredible to me that you you had
these show creators
that you had these two individuals one
guy on the mandalorian
somebody else who's about to become a
marvel superhero and the rest of the
cast
and you don't capitalize on that you
don't try and make something out of that
but you walk away at this point
to me i don't know what it was i i have
i
have no idea but it wasn't the networks
it was it was the creators
they were already signed up uh to do a
sixth season and
it all just came apart like that and
they're devastated as they as they
should be that's shocking news
yeah super sad it just sucks like during
these times covey
lockdowns everything that we're going
through these are the things we look
forward to is consistency in our
entertainment and our escapism so it's
sad that
you know in my opinion this is probably
to do with money it usually has
something to do with money or some way
in in the situation but
you know it just sucks that people are
not going to see their show come back
like i said yeah ashraf says why the
show is amazing fix the cbc
and he says i hope the kim's convenience
cast will be blessed with new
opportunities let's see hope for
um uh dan says kim's convenience is a
great show
and then who's this says um deborah says
maybe netflix will pick it up and
continue it yeah i know if netflix has
ever done that before have they done
that before they did that with lucifer
right
that show they that got canceled they
picked it up can't think of any other
show they've done that with yeah
netflix can do anything but but those
were all these these times when shows
have these
but these times when shows have been
saved where they have gone to netflix or
they went to the cw or whatever it was
these times that shows have been saved
the creators wanted the shows to go on
right so these other networks like
netflix would step in and say we will
give you a home
the problem here is that the creators of
the show
are the ones that are walking away so
what's netflix to do at this point when
the actual people who create the program
aren't there and are willing to create
it or even follow through
with a sixth season so i don't know
where those creators are going but the
next project they have better be
amazing right and joey just reminds me
too arrested development that was
another one that netflix picked up so
who knows we'll see but yeah people love
cube's convenience this isn't very
convenient
creators oh oh wow you're waiting for
that one
look at you excited this whole story was
just waiting
yeah when should i say that was perfect